[A] What is Aptos?
[A] What is Move?
[A] What are you building?
[B] My name is Chris Kim.
[B] I'm the developer relations engineer at Aptos Labs.
[B] Recently been creating a lot of AI tooling for developers
[B] because no one's manually coding anymore.
[B] Now we're building agent skills
[B] and all these cool AI tooling for people.
[A] What are you most passionate and excited about?
[B] Two main things that we're focusing on for 2026
[B] is Decimate Decimal and Shelby.
[B] Decentralized hot storage solution.
[B] So it's really like a good example for the world to see
[B] that, hey, if you really fully leverage
[B] the technology that Aptos offers.
[B] This is the type of product that you can build.